what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
taking an awful risk veda this had
better work
[Laughter]
for all you star wars fans out there uh
in this video we're going to be
explaining the captain britain core and
the reason why is because peggy carter
is as far as i understand it is slated
to appear in the first episode of what
if which she's going to basically be
captain britain although i think she's
called captain carter and so because we
have the multiverse and because she
referenced brian braddock in avengers
in-game it makes sense that they would
make her the first member of the captain
written core introduced to the mcu so
what is this team okay the captain
britain core technically did appear in
daredevil's number six back in june of
1983 but the reality is we didn't really
get an origin for the team until
excalibur vol 1 issue number 50. so
first things first here the origin as is
given to us actually runs directly in
line with the involvement of the phoenix
force and the way this worked was that
at one point in time in a different
dimension you had a guy by the name of
merlin now it's kind of a weird thing
and it's one of those scenarios where
marvel's history of merlin doesn't quite
line up so in model comics merlin is
exactly who you think he is right the
merlin of arthurian legend who was part
of king arthur knight's the round table
all that kind of stuff eventually he
elevated himself from that position to
heading what was basically the captain
britain core in a place called
otherworld he also existed in something
called the starlight citadel but the
important thing here is that this
particular origin of merlin from the
days of atlantis and all that kind of
stuff runs in direct contradiction with
the origin of merlin and excalibur
number 50 which says that he actually
comes from a different reality but
regardless of how you slice it his
involvement here came with a guy by the
name of necrom now necrom was this
alternate realities version of
essentially doctor strange right the
sorcerer supreme and the phoenix force
exists in an omniversal level basically
meaning there is a version of the
phoenix force in every single universe
but it's a part of a larger whole which
is the omniversal phoenix the reality
was that at this point in time the
phoenix had never really encountered
sentient beings and so when it
encountered necrom necrom tricked the
phoenix into basically creating these
kind of pillars across all of creation
across the entire multiverse so that all
this energy could be absorbed into these
pillars and then channeled into necrom
which would basically make him a
multiversal being when the phoenix
realized what was happening ultimately
it turned against necrom and the day was
safe but along the way you saw merlin
and you saw another guy named faron that
basically looked to defeat necrom as
well and that's what led to everything
kind of popping off the reality is that
in the aftermath of this necrom
presented the first instance where
merlin had come to the realization there
are beings out there who will threaten
the entirety of the multiverse and even
the omniverse right who will basically
look to conquer all of creation and so
in order to ensure that doesn't happen
there needed to be a kind of police
force a team more or less that could
serve the purpose of protecting each
universe across the multiverse and so as
a result of this merlin created the
captain britain core now the way this
works is the captain britain core each
of these guys exist in their own native
universe right so you have brian
braddock or at least now it's betsy
braddock but at one point it was brian
braddock who was the captain britain of
the maine marvel universe you have for
example spider-man uk who is a version
of captain britain from an alternate
reality this actually spider-man slash
captain britain you see this kind of
thing play out in these different
realities but the important thing here
is that these guys are basically powered
by what's called the friction of
universes and again this is one of those
instances where history and how people
describe the multiverse doesn't
necessarily line up when you talk about
alternate realities in marvel comics
they get displayed in different ways
sometimes they're displayed as being one
on top of the other right stacked the
way that the character of a mortise at
the end of loki described the multiverse
you look at something like jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers and
they exist side by side with each other
in all reality the formation and
organizational structure of the
multiverse is relative to whoever it is
that's telling that story that
particular point in time the important
thing is that the multiverse is a
collection of an infinite number of
universes now with regards to the
friction of universes this basically
moves forward in the ideology that
universes sit right next to each other
and that the energy they let off
basically bumps against itself and so
when one universe emanates its own
energy another universe is emanating
another energy that creates friction
that energy friction is what the captain
written core is powered by now again
this runs in the face of like somebody
like shumagorath right shumogorath for
example who's going to be in doctor
strange too he's what you call the mini
angled ones he exists or at least the
many angled ones themselves exists in
the space between universes so that's
how those kind of descriptions of the
multiverse don't really line up but the
important thing is that friction of
universes is how it is the captain
britain court is powered now as far as
their history goes here uh in
daredevil's issue number six again that
was when they first popped up something
i want to specify daredevils is not a
reference to matt murdock daredevil
instead back in the 1970s and 1980s
marvel didn't really have a presence
essentially anywhere outside the united
states
they were a u.s company but the desire
was to expand outside the united states
and so what they did is they basically
expanded into the united kingdom and
launched marvel uk which in reality was
just a reprint of existing stories that
had existed in in the united states as
they were produced by marvel comics
daredevils was one of those now a lot of
the stories were really more adult
oriented i mean it wasn't like marvel
max but it wasn't really stories that
were geared towards like kids so you saw
a few spider-man reprints only because
spider-man was so popular worldwide and
everybody wanted to get their hands on
him but by and large because it was
designed to be the british arm of marvel
comics it made good business sense to
give the british their own superhero so
that's why you ended up getting captain
britain now while merlin was technically
the omniversal guardian he was also
assisted by his daughter but the captain
britain core and the actions of merlin
existed in a couple different forms
right so you had merlin himself who was
kind of at the top of this group and
then you had his daughter roma who was
really more of an assistant than
anything else then you had saturnine or
saturn nine whatever you want to call
her and she was head of the omniversal
development court as the omniversal
magistrix and then you had the captain
written core and so it was almost kind
of like a governing body with a police
force of its own the omniversal
development court existed to make sure
that every universe progressed
essentially along the same lines right
so every universe had its own version of
like the avengers the x-men the
superheroes all arrived around the same
time different things along those lines
uh and the captain britain corps were
essentially protectors right now
whenever a universe didn't progress the
way it was supposed to say for example
there were no superheroes of any kind on
earth in that universe the omniversal
development court would initiate
something called the push where they
would basically jump start the
development of superhuman abilities on
that world and then it would basically
play catch-up right so the important
thing here is and then the reason why i
mentioned the omniversal development
court is the first real involvement and
really our first real introduction to
the captain britain corps came during
the crooked world storyline which
anybody who's familiar with this channel
knows i love the crooked world
this story is so awesome so the crooked
world introduced this this idea or a
villain a guy by the name of mad jim
jaspers and one of the things that we
learned and it was really exposure to
the nature of the omniversal development
court as a whole is that in this
alternate reality called earth 238 that
jim jaspers was a guy that had the
ability to alter reality but we didn't
really know the full extent of its
powers instead what you had was captain
britain brian braddock being sent on a
mission by merlin to this alternate
reality for the purpose of facing off
against the threat that was there and
this basically led to brian braddock
coming into contact with that alternate
reality version of mad jim jaspers what
we ended up learning is the reason why
no superheroes existed on that world is
because jim jaspers had used his powers
to create a being called the fury which
had the power to adapt to any superpower
that it came across and of course it was
programmed not to attack jim jasper's
because he didn't want a frankenstein's
monster kind of situation right where dr
frankenstein creates a monster then the
monster kills him right that's not
really what you wanted there
and so ultimately the fury wiped out all
the superheroes on earth the the
omniversal development court didn't know
this and so they initiated the push
which basically jump started superpowers
it pissed off jim jasper's he started
initiating what was called the jasper's
warp which was quite literally this
energy cyclone that emanated from jim
jasper's and started twisting up and
skewing up and literally warping the
entire fabric of reality to the point
that it almost spilled into the
multiverse the only way to stop it was
to basically destroy the entirety of the
jim jasper's uh universe itself and so
that reality's version of jim jasper's
was completely destroyed in the process
the fury survived and actually ended up
returning but as far as the captain
britain core goes this was our first
real introduction to the team itself
because we ended up learning that
reality's captain britain actually left
that universe and came to the main
marvel universe right just like a
refugee she was so traumatized by the
experience you would have like these
ptsd nightmares and all kinds of crazy
stuff but you eventually end up learning
that jim jasper's in that reality was
far weaker than jim jasper's in the main
marvel universe and that battle was
designed to be a test ultimately the
fight between brian braddock and jim
jasper's was really no fight at all
there's literally a point where like
brian braddock goes into the office of
jim jaspers who at that point had
basically got himself to the position of
prime minister and when he walks in he's
in this space that goes on forever and
jim jasper is just this enormous guy
right he's like are you lost in the fun
house it's crazy ultimately jim jasper's
is destroyed when the fury from his from
that destroyed universe ends up
teleporting into the main marvel
universe and then takes that jim jaspers
back to the the universe where nothing
exists because it realizes the only way
for jim jasper to use his powers is to
be in a place where there's matter for
him to manipulate in that giant white
void jim jasper's is totally powerless
so he's basically destroyed but the the
first introduction to the captain
britain core literally tells us they
were crushed
that they were that as a superhero team
sure they exist to try to protect you
know alternate realities or protect
their own realities from various threats
but it's really more of a ceremonial
role that in reality the way that roma
and merlin had set up the captain
britain corps is that whenever they
appear to a person and that person is
going to be chosen to become a member of
the corps they're presented with two
options the amulet of right or the sword
of might and the reason why these
options are given to them is because
it's basically a test the amulet of
might if it's chosen by a person who is
given the option to be a captain britain
denotes wisdom it denotes rational
thinking it denotes the idea that they
they look before they leap that they're
really more in line with diplomacy with
being a traditional superhero as opposed
to the the sword of might which means
they just want to destroy stuff
now sometimes a person who chooses the
sword of might is allowed to become a
captain britain but very rarely does
that ever happen instead if they choose
the sword of might they basically fail
the test and so sure they can keep their
weapon but they're not allowed into the
captain britain court uh for the rest of
the corps themselves they all consist of
individuals who have chosen the amulet
of right but the but even with that the
powers they have are not expansive right
they they have you know strength and
they have like the ability to fly and
they've got like some measure of speed
but they're not by any standard of
measurement the most powerful person
ever right they're not really capable of
facing off against like a cosmic entity
or something like that somebody like
spiderman could overcome a captain
britain right largely because of his
fighter sense but that's the level of
power that we're talking about here but
regardless as far as their history goes
you don't really see a lot of instances
when the captain written core comes
together as a whole instead most of the
captain britain core's involvement
really focuses largely on the individual
characters there'll be instances where
something pops off and you see the
entirety of the core come together and
basically meet in the starlight citadel
and it's like okay what are we gonna do
we form a plan we face off against that
threat and that's basically it but it's
not as though thanos will attain
something like the heart of the universe
which will allow him to destroy the
multiverse and the whole captain written
core symbols and faces off against him
and never really works that way the
closest that you came to that was in
1998 with fantastic four volume three
really issues number six through eight
in the aftermath of like the onslaught
saga and the idea that franklin richards
had created the whole uh heroes reborn
universe and was just walking around
with it what you ended up finding out is
that saturnine and roma had come to the
realization that because franklin's
powers have elevated to the point that
he can actually create pocket dimensions
that he's a clear and present danger to
all of creation and so what ended up
happening is saturnine basically sent
forward the tech net and the special
executive which are kind of like her own
personal you know bounty hunters
personal guard that kind of thing of
course they face off against a fantastic
four the fantastic four were able to
overcome them and that led to the
involvement of the captain britain court
now in reality despite the fact that the
captain britain corps does not have a
huge level of power this basically was a
war of attrition in the sense that
you're talking about a infinite number
of captain britons from a seemingly
infinite multiverse and so the numbers
just kept showing up they just kept
increasing over and over again and just
wore the fantastic four down now the
date was ultimately saved by johnny
storm who figured out what was going on
traveled to the realm of uh saturnine
and then realized like eternity and
infinity the cosmic entities were there
alongside galactus so it really was a
legitimate incredible threat in the form
of franklin ultimately a deal was struck
that because the concern was that people
might exploit franklin's powers and use
them to destroy all of creation that uh
the fantastic four would basically
ensure that never happened by keeping
franklin safe hence the reason why the
power dampeners were installed inside
his head and that if a time came when
somebody took franklin if the fantastic
four failed then saturnine and roma
could take franklin and then basically
keep him away from all of creation by
keeping him in the starlight citadel
that one and really the incursions is
the only time that you ever really saw a
complete unification of the captain
britain core with regards to any major
threat of course during the incursions
it was the map makers who were the
agents of the beyonders who basically
tricked the captain britain core into
following a beacon and when the captain
britain court arrived on the scene
believing that when they showed up there
they'd be able to quote unquote destroy
whatever was causing the collapse of the
multiverse it was a giant trap and they
were all basically obliterated even
saturnine herself was killed and and
really brian braddock was the only one
left alive the only one who was able to
escape and he only escaped because
saturnine basically gave him all the
information regarding the starlight
citadel and then literally threw him out
of there but again those are really the
only two times you see the captain
written core symbol for like a major
threat you do see moments where like
there'll be a symbol right but it's kind
of a throwaway thing a really good
example of this was during the events of
hickman's avengers new avengers while
that was going on you actually had the
spider-verse event which is when you had
spider-man uk who met with saturnine
saying like inheritors are traveling
around the multiverse killing spider-man
everywhere we find them and saturnine
didn't care right because she was
focused on stopping the the collapse of
the multiverse and roma actually gave uh
spider-man uk the at least some
assistance in helping him find different
spider-man and so on and so forth but
you know again you don't really see a
full unification of the captain written
court and even when you do it's not the
biggest deal in the world
the reason why this is so important
though when it comes to the marvel
cinematic universe is that it's
expanding the multiverse it's saying
like there's a much bigger multiverse
out there in the same way that nick fury
approached iron man at the end of the
first movie and said like you're part of
a much bigger scenario here than just
being a man in a metal suit right
there's a lot of people with powers out
there beside yourself this is what we're
talking about in the aftermath of loki
right presumably with marvel what if and
the introduction of captain carter
presumably being a member of the captain
britain core it's going to introduce to
us this idea that the the offhanded
remark of brian braddock in avengers
in-game was yes brian braddock is the
captain britain of the marvel cinematic
universe and that you know captain
carter is the captain of britain of her
what if universe and from the what if
series and there's a bunch of other
captain britain that exists out there
who were all part of a greater whole so
again there's huge ramifications as far
as the potential involvement of our
character with the kevin britton core
but we don't know for sure i'm just
making this video on a hunch and
hopefully my hunch turns out to be true
it might not and it may just be that
she's just a version of captain america
and that's it there's nothing more to it
than that so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace